taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
t-a-s-t-e budge wow that was like like
that's how it starts just with the tea
I forgot to say here we are welcome to
no I like it it's almost like it's
almost like you screeched in like Dukes
of Hazzard you realize you weren't ready
yeah sorry uh no it's good you liked it
one of the things they say in uh in
improv which I know you love is uh it's
to start a scene right in the middle
already don't don't mess around starting
the action that's what you just did you
wanna know how bad I am at improv yeah
Mary Lynn rice cup you know Maryland I
don't know she's a lovely person and
very funny and amazing and improv super
yeah I did a uh oh she's a stand-up too
though yeah uh and I did I did a show
with her not with her like we were on a
show together in in LA
and the premise of the show was they had
people do stand up they'd stand up to
stand up and then they had improv people
do improv and then they made everybody
flip and they made the stand-ups do
improv and The Improv people do stand up
well that's that's in your favor because
if they don't have material they don't
have material it wasn't in my favor okay
because I got paired up with Mary libb
and they said here's the scenario you
you work at Starbucks and she's a she's
a great customer and she came in and I'm
so mad at improv I said all I could
think of to say was I really thought you
were great on 24. which is what she
really does
think of anything dude I'm so bad at it
like I was like I don't understand
improvise here all the whole day
it's like we did I won't spoil we did it
we did a sort of an improv last night on
the live stream and I didn't
I started doing the fake conversation it
was my conversation it was so bad if I'm
in a scene like if I'm acting in a scene
and they're like just keep going like
Let It Go but there's like a premise and
like lines and I'm like oh I could go
that's a little bit easier but if you
literally just go like okay boom boom
boom go like I'm like I I'm lost yeah
like the fact that people do that and
make it funny
but I can do crowd work kind of like I
don't understand you're just you you
have the skill set you just not don't
know how to apply it like you know there
are some fundamentals that'll get you
like that'll at least give you a little
push immediately you know but it's
basically just following
following and adding it's all it is it's
it's it's it's it's affirming and adding
it's affirming and adding yes and is the
the big blah blah but it's true it works
you're just building something you build
you build
um
what uh we're well let's not talk about
what we were talking about yeah I don't
want to talk about that but uh we were
uh we were we're here to oh boy look I'm
sorry I just started thinking about it
I'm sorry you got two guys here that you
know can really hyper focus on stuff and
can can worry and we're not gonna get
into it because it comes up all the time
now because rightfully so because it's
it's what's in the news all the time and
it keeps getting more updated it's just
this Ai and its threat to humanity We're
not gonna go there instead of talking
about Ai and the threat to humanity we
will talk about bacon and eggs and Cold
Cereal yes I almost think we can get
right into the battle okay because I
feel like there's a lot
of uh meat on this bone
as you like to say yeah
uh you know I mean this is a pretty
this is a pretty big battle I mean this
is like
this is you know I mean we're talking
about the the titans of breakfast here
yeah this is like you know there are
people out there that love pancakes that
hate pancakes they're people out there
that love waffles they hate waffles
they're people that think oatmeal is
great they're people that think it's
disgusting
some people love a half a grapefruit
other people think it's the most uh you
know it's torturous or whatever
sometimes you feel like a nut sometimes
you don't that's true you know but I
gotta say
you picture breakfast
I mean this these are the two things you
you picture you see a bowl of cereal in
your head or you see bacon and eggs
that's a decent point but I'm not really
leaning into what do you think of when
you think of breakfast I'm leaning into
what do I prefer if I had to choose now
I'm not even saying I love bacon and
eggs I'm not even saying that I mean let
me get that straight let me say let me
rephrase that I do love bacon and eggs
when I'm in the mood for it
um and I and it hits a spot and
sometimes you just want bacon but
actually a lot of times I do not want
bacon myself
and I know one's hot and one's protein
and I know mine is like usually not
nutritious and has sugar so as far as
nutritionally there really is no debate
there but when I'm talking about I will
be pointing what I would debate I
pointed it out I will be hammering that
yeah but I already did no but I will be
but you don't even need to but I will be
but it's already a point that I'm making
for you no but I will be fine fair
enough all right if you have if you
don't have enough other things then just
double up on that
um
he's on one today folks did we go Batley
buds no we didn't start yet we didn't do
the other buttons okay all right that's
fair because I did the other thing
shitty and you did all right
um I'm more like okay do you want to do
an eye no matter what happens I love you
because because last I kind of eat it
ready yeah sure all right all right
let's just skip it
oh boy we're not in a good way today no
I'm in a good way
I'm not in a good way actually but I'm
not either but it has nothing to do with
skipping no matter what I love you no I
I know but I feel like we're both kind
of blah today and like and like the fact
that we don't want to reach over and
touch each other and do the chant like I
feel like there's a reflection of that
I know
on the live show yeah the live show I
gotta tell you I have been I have been
stressed to my gills for a number of
reasons
and I really thought that once we got
and I even said to to Sal last night I
just had to get through this live stream
so I could exhale and it's it wasn't
that I was very sorry
sucks I'm just like oh I woke up today
feeling the way I've been feeling and I
was like oh [__] it wasn't the live
stream that was stressing me out like
and it was not a good realization yeah
you know like so I I know that I'm
stressed right now because I'm starting
to I'm doing the thing in my head where
I'm like
maybe I should just go get a whiskey
after that like it's like when I start
thinking like that I'm like uh oh yeah
like this is ooh like I don't know if I
should be yeah um anyway
I'm looking at it is uh without a doubt
uh I'm I I could eat cereal every day
and I'm more in the mood for cereal than
I am for bacon eggs when I say I need to
be in the mood for bacon and eggs you
know I could have it I could really be
craving it but just like you know the
go-to the simple thing the fun thing the
thing that really is consistent from kid
to now uh uh is a cereal for me I mean
there's a massive variety I mean an egg
is an egg and bacon is bacon they're a
200 cereals you know uh all to fit your
liking they there can be healthy cereals
not they're all not great and they can
be cereals that are bad for you but
cereal is fun
cereal is easy cereal
um you don't have to if you want cereal
you're having cereal in 30 seconds
you're not cooking anything you're not
cracking eggs you're not cleaning grease
off a pan okay
um cereal perfect snack whenever really
uh we're talking I just wrote choose one
so we're not exclusively talking
breakfast we know we can eat all of
these whenever people have breakfast for
dinner but I love like settling into
like you know
uh I will say
um
aside from I I want to talk about the
sustenance but not from a nutritional
standpoint because as you pointed out
it's no contest one is basic well but I
actually there's a healthy version of
cereal and there's a version of syrup
it's the [__] nobody wants but you know
you could eat the high fiber whatever
and go you know that actually does give
me there are benefits to that or
whatever low sugar so high five you know
way low way lower in fat than bacon and
eggs and cholesterol most most cereal in
fact even the worst kinds for you are
zero cholesterol right
so so I would say sure you got
cholesterol there you got saturated fat
you got grease you got I don't is there
saturated fat oh no yeah but no trans
fat right yeah but uh okay but so I
would say I would say
there's there's a healthy way there's a
healthier way to eat both of these you
could eat egg whites you could eat
turkey bacon you could not fry it in
butter you could bake the egg you could
bake the bacon they're they're you could
hard boil the egg the indulgent version
is the best version though of course of
both of both Foods you if you're gonna
do these you want Captain Crunch versus
Sunny Side Up greasy bacon you know or
scrambled greasy bacon right so I prefer
the Sunny Side Up these days but uh I
will just say from a sustenance
place I don't even know if I'm using the
right word no yes I will start with
sustenance if you got a long day ahead
of you and you wake up hungry sure that
protein is going to carry you sure yeah
you know construction there's a reason
there's protection workers in a diner
eating chicken and eggs fortified
cereals as well sure sure but I you know
but I will say this this is my biggest
viewers this is my biggest argument Pro
bacon eggs
there's a satisfaction quality it brings
that this brings that I cannot get from
cereal as much as I love cereal I can
sitting and I'll give you the two
versions of it
sitting I'll give you this I'm sorry I
keep cutting myself off uh but I I will
give you both for try to give here's the
better sorry you can't help it the
Pier's the second favorite of the two
and then I'll give you my favorite
waking up
it's a cozy Winter's morning or it's a
beautiful Breezy Summer Morning Sun
shining you open the windows you got the
breeze going the fresh air is going
there's just nothing like hey guys let's
have breakfast and like you pull out the
skillet and you make eggs and you smell
the bacon and you get it going that is
incredible especially if you're in a
house with guests when we go away there
will be a day when that happens and that
is going to lift everybody's spirits
like cartoon style like your nose lifts
you out of bed and you follow the
scent to the kitchen right floating
that's an um that's what I mean what
happens with fruit loops too that's an
amazing experience but my favorite
Sam that was the whole advertising
campaign follow my nose yeah that's true
that is but my favorite is there is just
nothing more satisfying when you want
breakfast going into a diner sitting at
that countertop and you get eggs and
bacon and black coffee and you sit there
ju you just sit there like it's
time for business like you you sit there
with your thoughts and you just go
through it and you sip the coffee and
you and you dip the bacon in the yolk
and I mean you're just like you feel
like a gr you feel like an adult you're
like it's I have a day ahead of me right
but conversely sometimes cereals makes
me feel like a kid again and I love that
cereal is fun it's it's it's it's it's
it was like obviously marketed toward
children at one point but it's fun it's
colorful uh uh I mean don't even get me
started on the prizes okay growing up me
and my sister used to I think that's I'm
gonna allow it but I think that's an
unfair thing to bring into the argument
I think that's unfair who you're going
to allow it who you judge you know we do
this how is it unfair it's literally
it's married to the to the to the
experience of the cereal I think I think
certain cereals do it I think you're
honing it on a specific thing that sure
materials do sure I am I don't think I
don't think it fairly speaks to which of
these Foods is better I don't think that
an attribute of cereal is a toy is in
the box but it but sir but certainly it
is I mean obviously sure it's it's not
like in every box but it's completely
part of the experience of some of it it
was fully and holy part of my growing up
serial experience and it's one of the
things that made cereal so you know
desired by me I think that would be like
me saying uh Easter egg hunts are are
part of my argument
because
Easter is so fun like you know you hard
boil the egg and you die you're talking
about eating right that's what I'm
saying the toy is not part of eating the
toy is a separate
the kid quality to me as you're eating
something with pink marshmallows inside
of it but you know you know what it'd be
like let me make the comparison it'd be
like if you open a dozen eggs and there
was a prize in there
that's that's really the only comparison
to me
actually what if that was the mo I mean
that's the mo all right then I would say
I would say part of the experience that
I will then I will see your toy argument
with uh and then as far as I'm concerned
this is an anti-up uh
I have tons of friends at this point who
have their own chickens in their
backyard and they get fresh eggs every
day out of their own backyard you can't
do that with cereal you can't make your
own cereal you can't give back in your
own weird small way to society by having
a Serial animal in the back use that
shit's Cocoa Puffs you certainly can
customize cereal though you can
customize it I mean I I have my Cheerios
I cut a banana in that [__] you can
customize I'm saying I put blueberries
I'm just well of course you can
customize it I'm saying though you can't
you're you can't make it well I'm saying
like you're kind of when you're adding
stuff to it you're kind of making a
bespoke version of it for yourself I
think that's a bit of a stretch well
bowl of cereal alone or [__] bananas
and some sprinkled sugar or whatever it
is in there is a different two different
dishes my point is is you can't say a
benefit of cereal is you can get your
own chicken and get cereal for for
almost nothing and and help contribute
to a societal issue of overpriced eggs
like I think that's a huge attribute to
the egg that you could literally get a
chicken and get your own eggs yeah I'm
not comparing what I just said to that
I'm just saying it as its own thing and
like you know well I could put ketchup
on my eggs or hot sauce you know any any
food that allows me ketchup in hot sauce
I think people
um folks let's talk about butcher box
one of my fav sponsors here at the taste
buds podcast uh I love the options and
the deals butcher boxes offering going
to the grocery store can be a real pain
in the tucus and I like that butcher box
is bringing me Quality Meat at
affordable prices conveniently
uh you want grass-fed beef you want
cage-free chicken you want humanely
raised pork that's crate free you want
wild caught Seafood these things are
hard to find and they are they're even
harder to find at prices that are
affordable to you I personally like the
steaks I'm a big red meat guy I know
we're not supposed to eat tons of red
meat all the time but if you're gonna
eat it you should eat it in the
healthiest way possible and butcher box
helps me do that allows me to do that in
a way that I can afford to do it it's
convenient I don't like it taste out a
whole portion of going to the
supermarket you don't have to shop for
anything they send you everything and
you have it in the freezer you have it
when you need it you could it's a
description service you can curate it
yourself the fact that it's cheaper is
crazy it's like I can't wrap my head
around that it it's more you know
usually you go well if you get it
delivered sure but then it's going to be
more money because it's free shipping
always yeah you can curate you can
customize your own boxes and there's
recipe inspiration guides tips and hacks
butcher boxes giving you guys a special
deal sign up today using Code taste buds
to receive ground beef for a year plus
20 off your first order How great is
that two pounds of ground beef it's free
in every single box for one year yeah
plus 20 bucks off that first order so
you're gonna go sign up at
butcherbox.com Taste Buds and use promo
code taste buds again butcherbox.com
taste buds with promo code taste buds
folks folks let's talk about our sponsor
next Evo CBD CBD is a substance that a
lot of people like utilizing these days
why well because a lot of us are anxious
a lot of us aren't sleeping properly a
lot of us need a little assist in
staying calm and a lot of us want to do
that in a natural way not doing it with
some sort of prescription medication
sure and next Evo Naturals is exactly
that I have taken it um I it helps me
de-stress it helps me unwind at the end
of the day don't take it every day I
take it when I particularly feel like
I'm having you know having trouble
relaxing winding down or a really
stressful day yeah and it's it's just
natural they develop smart sword
technology and and what that does is
it's clinically proven to help your body
absorb the CBD four times faster than
let's say regular CBD oil it also works
faster so when you need to de-stress
reach for uh the next Evo products okay
sleep better it's the summertime you're
going to want to sleep better there's
nothing worse than Austin and turning I
can't stand it and especially in a in a
season like the summer when you want to
be rested so you can get up and attack
the beautiful sunshiny days so check out
next Evo it's a CBD you can enjoy no
matter what wherever the summer takes
you the all-natural products are backed
by more scientific studies than any
other CBD brand developed by experienced
consumer health care and pharmaceutical
professionals stay well this summer with
smartener CBD from next Evo Naturals go
to nextevo.com
tastebuds that's
n-e-x-t-e-v-o.com taste buds to get 20
off your first order of forty dollars or
more that's 20 percent off at next Evo
NEX
tevo.com
taste buds a lot of people uh have a
favorite cereal multiple favorite
cereals uh I think it's a feel-good food
when you have your cereal in there and
you're like you know what let me have
it's a comfort I think that people get
emotionally attached to cereal and I
think an emotional attachment when you
is something that is worth mentioning
because it means that you
you want it not just for like eating it
I don't know what it is but like you
know you get attached as a kid to Toucan
Sam or or Tony the Tiger you know you're
like you know you kind of you kind of
just kind of like it it has that a
cereal has an identity every seal has a
different identity and in that respect
the possibilities are endless I mean
yeah you could yeah you could Sunny Side
Up it and you can scramble it but I
could I could have hundreds of options
with the cereal I would say I think
I think that
both have their own identity I think
they're they're different types of
identities though meaning this
I think with cereal it offers this is
the better way to phrase it I think what
you're saying is it's a comfort food
absolutely
I think they're Comfort Foods in
different they're different styles of
comfort Foods though cereal is a comfort
food in the way that
your favorite cartoon from childhood
makes you feel warm inside it's that
kind of thing bacon and eggs to me is a
comfort food in the sense of like it's
like Americana like it's just it's like
bacon and eggs could almost go on the
flag and you'd be like yeah that makes
sense it certainly is it certainly is
the PowerHouse of breakfast I mean it's
for sure it's just it's for sure there's
just nothing there's just nothing else
like it at breakfast it is the breakfast
food it is the one if you told me for
breakfast for dinner bacon and eggs are
coming into that mix and people love
breakfast I mean cereal is 24 7 now you
could have at any minute of the day yeah
but you can't cereal you cannot have if
you said we're having breakfast for
dinner and I put out cereal you'd be
like come on dude where's the where's
the eggs where's the pancakes what else
we got here oh that's kind of a mystery
all I'm saying is like cereal transcends
breakfast though cereal is I know I know
but I'm saying like cereal is is it it
is a snack it's it's it's a it's candy
basically no no no no yeah this there's
hundreds of varieties and a lot of them
are not candy I know but let's there's
oats yeah are you enjoying that this is
fiber there's brand I yeah I do love it
I love old I love all cereals I don't
know my point is is like you're not
eating a bowl of bread flakes for dinner
or for lunch you eat it for breakfast no
I eat it whenever I want and you might I
know but I'm saying what you said is not
does not apply I'm saying the only meal
it could be is breakfast that's it or
outside of breakfast it's a snack
no I I've never seen if you have you
have two bowls of something for
breakfast you had breakfast if you
decide to have those two bowls of lunch
you had zero for lunch I have never in
my life seen a human being including
myself I'm saying this I've never seen
it I'm not saying it doesn't exist I'm
saying I've never seen it I have never
seen a human being eat cereal for lunch
like I've just never seen it okay but I
mean so I'm sure it's common every day I
don't think it's common I think that I
don't I think that cereal serves two
purposes it's either breakfast or it's
late night snack I don't think that
cereal comes in it certainly is not a
dinner food people don't eat cereal for
dinner come on dude you know that they
don't you can eat cereal at any time you
can eat anything you could eat anything
any time of the day if you so choose
that's what we're talking about I'm
saying to you you would never eat cereal
for dinner
do you want me to lie to you I don't
know what to say I've done it does it
disappoint you that I've done it
I mean I've done it I've eaten
everything though can you give me
something on this that it's it's not
something people do traditionally no
people don't want a cold bullets here
for dinner but that's yes but that's
okay whereas bacon and eggs could be any
meal and people do in fact eat it at any
meal let me let me pose you this if you
told me right now that this next
calendar week for seven days I had to
have bacon and eggs every morning I
would not that would not appeal to me I
would be like yeah that's an Overkill
I'm not gonna want bacon in the next
seven days in a row
if you were like
hey all we got for cereal for breakfast
this week is cereal I'd be like okay I
wouldn't bat an eye I would be horrified
if you told me I had to eat cereal for
breakfast horrified it's the word to go
with yes yes I can't say I even said
that it wouldn't appeal to me I I would
be hard hyperbolic I can't think of a
worse way to start my day okay for two
reasons I'm telling you I will I will
expound uh for two reasons any cereal I
would want to eat is horrid for me and I
will feel guilt and lethargic and every
terrible thing that you can feel from
eating a bowl of sugar
and any cereal that is good for me is
revolting and I don't want to eat it yes
that's it like that's it that's your
application of cereal it's different for
everybody
okay but your thing was your application
of bacon and eggs sure yeah but like but
I'm saying I even like bacon and eggs
but I can't eat it seven days in a row I
I wouldn't want to eat bacon and eggs
seven days in a row I wouldn't eat
anything seven days in a row I I you you
like to often make that argument of if I
had to eat at seven I don't want to I
don't ever want to eat anything well
it's hypothetical Joe but um but you but
I'm saying hypothetical to like lean
into a point I don't think it's a good
point I think eating anything Ad nauseam
is why the term Ad nauseam it's a
perfect application of the term I don't
want I don't want to eat anything seven
days in a row my point is is if you told
me hey dude on the days that you want
breakfast and have to eat breakfast you
have to either eat cereal or bacon and
eggs and you pick which days you want to
do that I would say bacon and eggs now
fairly and this is me taking my personal
[__] out of it I don't eat bacon and
eggs anymore in the morning because my
stomach as I get older I can't do a
heavy breakfast anymore and it's too
heavy for me the bacon gives me uh
heartburn I get a little stomachache
from the eggs uh so so but I also don't
do cereal okay if I had to um
if I had my way this is neither category
technically it's hot cereal but that's
not what we're doing here no it's cold I
said signify cold I would do you give me
an apple and cinnamon Quaker Oats
Oatmeal every morning I'm not mad at you
you know what I mean I'm just not it's
it's it's it's warm well let's do that
let's do that in a battle if you love
that I love because I I've been I've
been thinking of the French toast
French toast yeah versus oatmeal we'd
have to broaden it up a little bit maybe
we'd be a little specific can you say
apples and cinnamon oatmeal is that
broad enough I don't think that's broad
enough people I think when they think of
oatmeal they get like raisins and syrup
and [__] hmm
yeah I've only ever seen apples and
cinnamon oatmeal by the way in the Quake
roach packets whenever you get it in a
restaurant they they bring out oatmeal
and then they bring out like you're a
bartender yeah they're like here are
bowls of things and whatever you want to
do yeah like uh but uh can I can I add a
point to the cereal I did cereal
is fun to eat of course I like the fact
that
you know at first you control the milk
ratio
you control how fast you want to eat it
so you can get some dry or crunchy
cereal on top you you know as every
person who eats cereal has a method and
a preferred method and I think that is a
very good attribute of cereal and I like
the fact that it takes you on a journey
you're crunching up top you're medium in
the middle if you so choose you could
wait get soggy I didn't even start
talking about the milk
the milk at the end is just a whole
another thing that only happens with
cereal and everyone I don't I've never
met a person that doesn't love cereal
milk I will take over cereal milk yeah I
I've enjoyed cereal milk when I when I
eat cereal absolutely it's like a cherry
on but over cereal milk I will take
dunking buttered toast into egg yolk I
mean it's just it's just the greatest
thing of all time toast you can't apply
here okay well then donkey even dunking
the bacon into it okay dunking into an
egg yolk is is oh my God man yeah unreal
I gotta be honest with you I scramble uh
90 90 of the time because
if I do decide to do a runny egg
actually there's a 50 50 shot that I'm
gonna be grossed out by it it has this
slimy and then you start thinking what
am I doing dear God
this is an aborted chicken
okay all right I mean you can get
salmonella if you're not or not cooked
properly I'm bringing Slaughters that
you're not right now I mean it almost
looks like a muc like a phlegm like a
yellow phlegm and like I don't know man
just sometimes sometimes it could really
really gross me out that might be a pro
it's closer to the magic of life rather
than just processed food
I don't feel like eating placenta oil I
will say I will say to Pimp's Point most
diets most modern day diets will allow
you some form of egg some form of bacon
whatever whether it's in moderation or
not you can have it they're in a diet on
planet Earth that goes you should eat
cereal in the morning no that's not true
at all a one cup of cereal with the
right milk and and it's healthy is is
totally a good way to start your day
with a well-balanced breakfast I've read
it
this cereal that promotes heart health
the heart health thing is real iffy with
cereals I mean Cheerios claims you get
your protein you get your fiber it did
this cereals that are not bad for you
you know you can you can be healthy no
it's all about the suggestion portions I
know but it's it's even the ones that
aren't bad for you it's heavy carbs
heavy carbs man but you'll load lump on
cholesterol on insane fat and Grease
still and it's still processed it's
still no matter which way you slice it
cereal is a heavily processed food it
comes out of a factory you know can't
argue that it's it's it's it's one of
the reasons it's it's it's not playing
as big of a role worm family breakfast
versus divorced dad crying through his
Rice Krispies for dinner that's funny
um uh so so
I had a point in my ADHD kicked in hold
on you know what I like too that you can
um that if you want more cereal if you
decide you want more cereal it's also
really fun when you've got milk left you
finish zero to pour in that second
second pour of cereal sure maybe it's a
little lighter maybe 50 lighter but you
pour it in because you can tailor
exactly how much you want to eat now if
you eat a couple eggs and a couple of
strips of bacon you're still hungry you
got to go back and start cracking eggs I
think that that's a I think that I
actually think that's a huge attribute
to my breakfast I think it's I think
that is one of the biggest detriments in
the world with cereal you eat it too
quickly you a lot of with a lot of
brands are getting a sugar high from it
of some kind and right then and there
you put you refill and you overeat
because of that I think eating sitting
I'm still hungry I wish I had more eggs
well I don't five minutes go by
oh [__] I'm actually glad I didn't eat
more right just then I feel good like I
think that that's a huge problem but
you're applying just sugary cereals to
that like I could have even even a nut
sugar cereal I I think the access of it
it's it's too easy and I think it leads
to overeating a lot of the time dude if
you ate the portion even with a healthy
cereal if you ate the portion they told
you to eat it's insane dude you're like
what
what like nobody eats that portion it's
like the ice cream servings the Brian
Regan
Two Scoops well you know whatever I also
love the box man I love I love reading
the Box all sides I love
um when the box has games on it you know
maybe it has a couple of uh word games
maybe it has a maze I'm gonna I'm gonna
top your shirt I like that I like
Gardens redefining art classes across
[Laughter]
I think so yeah I mean they must be what
else are they gonna do yeah but I'm
saying like it's a companion piece to
the meal in and of itself you know you
sit at the table and the box is in front
of you and everybody reads every part of
that box it's just it's just fun yes but
but you're you're also going now back to
a certain kind of cereal no no because I
also will read the Box
even when there's no games I just mean
it's like uh it's it's a
like I said
people have
they have a routine with cereal there's
a way to eat it and it's different for
everybody
I can't argue with that uh I'll go a
step further though bacon and eggs
I well you might say that this is
doesn't count but you're making a
sandwich with cereal you make a sandwich
with bacon and eggs does that count
is that fair
um I mean it's it becomes something
different but uh
you know because if you're because if
you need the bread it's something
different like you could eat one scoop
of bacon an egg on a fork and that's not
the same as having a bacon egg and
cheese all right I mean or bacon and egg
on you know on bread well that's the
other thing with eggs man we didn't even
get into that throwing cheese on the
eggs you want to talk about adding
ingredients making it your own peppers
onions tomato fresh tomato uh uh other
meats uh jeez I do think the Omelette is
is overrated
I I actually excuse me I am actually not
a huge omelet fan again
my favorite egg is a sunny side up
followed by a scrambled I'm not a huge
omelet guy but it doesn't mean that it's
not a
Titan
Titan Force for the eggs the omelet with
bacon inside of it an omelette station
they got an omelette station
what about those fun cereal dispenses
where you turn it at the same place and
it's gonna talk about I was going to say
or the little boxes they're even more
fun you guys feel like a giant buddy you
got you got an omelette station you got
a guy back there
you know dress like he's going to slice
prime rib he's got the hat on and
everything he's cooking it right in
front of you he's going crazy he's got
all the ingredients it's like watching
it's like watching one of those Japanese
guys yeah Hibachi guys and then you go
down and you have a series of sad tubes
I actually love it it looks like a Doc
Brown invention and you pull the thing
out he goes I also will tell you that
you just made me think of something else
I also like the option to empty the bags
into cereal Tupperware and then seeing
the array of different uh varieties you
have right in front of you I also like
the fact that if you want cereal at one
of those stations you're not sitting
there waiting for the dope in front of
you and you're not sitting there waiting
for them to cook that thing you just
you're getting your cereal and you're
eating you're going hard in the paint on
this not having to wait thing I think
the having the weight thing is a good
thing I think it's mannerly I think it's
it it exercises patience I think the
accessibility of cereal is a is a bad
thing it's a problem you can get to it
too quickly and too easily and it leads
to an over a a too high in intake knock
knock
who's there the cereal bar
cereal bar who
cereal bar
it was supposed to end there what it was
supposed to end there the hell are you
talking about a joke I'm just
introducing the cereal bar into making
any sense what do you mean
I said knock knock I prompted you I knew
you would take it and then understand
what that meant you said who's there I
said the cereal bar right as adults
talking I figured that you would
understand that that was just my way to
intro the cereal I've never seen an
adult intro something like that I mean
you said back to me cereal bar because I
thought it was a joke you had by the way
by the way you know who doesn't have
cereal or cereal bars
Mickey D's baby oh no
God damn it
you gotta stop it they got the big
breakfast baby I don't know how you
didn't bring up McDonald's during pencil
pen but I thought you should I did I
think I did yeah I said pen is the
McDonald's
I did you have problems
yeah folks game time they're here to
help you get rid of that stress when
it's time to buy tickets for your
favorite upcoming events it's the
One-Stop shop for last minute ticket
deals there's Flash Deals uh they
guarantee the lowest price if you if you
find uh the same tickets in the same
section or rose with a lower price they
will refund you 110 that's amazing
that's amazing and we're talking any
events sporting event concert whatever
it is theater sports playoff games
whatever it is they also let you see
um the view from your exact seat which
is huge yeah I think that is huge
because you don't know what some
sometimes you get to the place there's
something blocking you know exactly
seating Maps seating images uh letting
you buy tickets in a matter of seconds
uh it's just it's all and by the way
it's all sent directly to your phone so
you never have to dig through your email
to find the tickets or anything like
that
game time's just making it easy why
because they want you to get to the
event and enjoy the event not stress out
trying to figure out how to do all that
just another thing is what about when
you find out something day of that you
didn't even know exactly you know what I
mean not that you've been waiting months
but it's like holy
geez yeah well I also I like I like to
because I'm a last minute kind of guy
with with the way my schedule goes and I
like that there is a service that lets
me know okay if I go there and I see
what the tickets are listed for most
likely that's the best possible price
and for some reason it's not they're
gonna back it with the 110 uh uh money
back nag the tickets without the stress
with Game Time download the game time
app create an account use the code taste
buds for 20 off your first purchase
terms apply again you just got to create
an account and redeem the code using
taste buds for twenty dollars off
download game time today last minute
tickets lowest price guaranteed what's
up guys first things first the
Impractical Jokers cruise is happening
January 22nd to the 26 2024 we are
hosting it with Eric Andre uh there's
gonna be a ton of comics and bands and
DJs it's our fifth one you can get
tickets right now it's 65 sold out uh at
pre-sale so get tickets right now at get
ship faced cruise.com you can also enter
to win a free trip and practical jokers
are finishing out the first leg of our
tour now through July all uh dates and
tickets are available at
impracticaljokerslive.com in the coming
weeks we have Minneapolis Des Moines
Kansas City Nashville uh St Louis and
I'm not forgetting anything
that's it
folks Joe DeRosa here my new record
the penthouse papers collected readings
is dropping with a special thing records
on June 9th I had a two year long op-ed
column with Penthouse uh magazine and we
got all my columns together and I read
them into a microphone and from that
microphone to your ears how about that
folks it's a nice easy listen it's sort
of like an audio book I want you to
check it out I think you're going to
like it I'm really proud of the writing
I'm really proud of the pieces I was
proud of them when they ran in the
magazine and I'm still proud of them and
I hope you enjoy them and that's why we
put this all together also if you're in
New York come to Joey Rose's open seven
days a week 11 30 a.m each morning open
into the night sandwiches available all
day long affordable drinks affordable
food always a good time Joey Rose's
nyc.com for detail and you can get that
album where digitally on any platform
you stream your music from and if you
want to buy it you can actually pay to
download it from one of those sites like
iTunes that'll charge you but anyway no
physical release just a digital thing
to lull you to sleep each night
um yeah man uh let's go to Let's what
time is it let's go to the phones yeah
yeah
let's go let's take some calls
yeah it's all right we'll still talk
wait but I just want to see what's up
all right yeah let's do some some phones
for inspiration on talking points I know
Sal chose cereal magic spoon got their
hooks in him and he never escaped I will
say one thing at the top of this I also
thought before even doing this I I think
that it's weight it's definitely waiting
for bacon and eggs it's a hot dish I'm I
don't know I think people are gonna get
into the comfort food of cereal I mean
if Seinfeld was Voting it'd be cereal I
know I look cereal is going to be a
tough opponent here Shiro isn't always
will be the king of breakfast
fast and simple
uh egg eggs and bacon all day because
cold zero in the morning is like getting
recruited to the Army I don't understand
that
when I go unhealthy I want a full heart
attack bacon and eggs imagine looking at
these options and picking the one that
starts with the word gold I just said
that that's fine it's hot yeah that's
very funny do you want to read some sure
I could do it but why squint you know I
want hold on
I'm a vegetarian I chose eggs because I
I like having Joy
okay
I despise milk
all right
oh well okay chicken legs can sustain me
until dinner
that is true if you got a coast oh hold
on hold on I'm sorry if you're talking
about for dinner Cold Cereal all the way
now if you could rewind the tape about
seven minutes when he said I've never
ever no one has ever I've never ever
heard of someone wanting to have cold
cereal for dinner I mean there was
someone staring at you when you when you
said that that does it right here I
stand by what I said
but the if a child ever said to you my
mom gave us cold Center for cereal for
dinner that sentence is followed by she
was an alcoholic
thank you for clarifying the cereal
isn't warm well let me tell you
something Anna there's [__] hot
cereal it's called oatmeal I think she
might well before you jump on her I
actually was going to say I'm on her
already I think she might be saying
thank you for Claire like me I don't she
might not be exactly okay all right
uh I can eat like four bowls of cold
cereal for great two eggs two pieces of
bacon I feel like my arteries are
clogging there you go nobody awakens
from their sleep to the lovely smell of
cold cereal and rushes downstairs crispy
and fluffy protein versus soggy carbs I
put my Frosted Flakes in the microwave
then add milk to it so would it be hot
or cold I've never heard God this guy's
a pig
yeah I don't even understand what that
experience is that is nasty but but
I'm more intrigued I I mean you're still
eating the exact same thing it's just
that the flakes are warm you ever
microwave milk it like curdles no he
doesn't he doesn't microwave the milk he
microwaves the Frosted Flakes and then
he adds milk
yeah no I read it wrong I thought he put
put the whole thing in the way that's
less bad than I thought yeah I don't
know I don't I don't really know what I
can't imagine what that experience is
like I will try that
uh I'm a vegetarian and I know eggs and
bacon is better eggs and bacon are
better more Dynamic I mean I've gotten
walloped
wakey wakey eggs and bakey identity
I forgot there's a saying around mine
man a man eggs and bacon rule but
there's something about cereal when you
get it in your mind you just gotta have
it I have stronger emotional connection
with cereal
as sad as that may sound no we talked
about it even before that cold cereal is
my Munchies food but I also love some
eggs and bacon but it's only Superior to
cereal on everything bagel so there you
go cereal Cinnamon Toast Crunch boom
please one of the worst cereals ever
invented
uh on American of me but I strongly
dislike bacon the texture is just the
taste is so bad I loaded eggs and bacon
but a bowl of cereal is acceptable at
all 24 hours of the day
I don't like eggs but I love bacon Cold
Cereal like cereal yes Carly you can't
get cold cereal at McDonald's
uh can you get his contact information
we just found a soul mate
Cold Cereal is my come home drunk wake
up hungover food gobble up that cold
milky goodness
I'm shelving that bacon and eggs it's so
tasty I'm giving shelving I don't
understand what that means shoveling I
think he meant to say I don't know I
don't know what that I don't get that
one
I don't like eggs I Cold Cereal crunches
better than a bacon crunch I mean it
looks like you have the weight on on
your side for sure I've never even I've
I've seen I've ever never been set full
inside but they switched it yeah well
meanwhile the next guy says nah it's
cereal because there's more variety Cold
Cereal is ink eating and drinking at the
same time oh that's that's fun it's
Seinfeld's line oh is it
yeah the Q a at the end of the the HBO
special they go why do you what what's
up with you and Cyril and he goes
there's something about eating and
drinking at the same time
my chickens may stop laying eggs if I
don't say eggs but bacon is the one that
doesn't seem too Fair
what
I don't know all right
some people these tweets are like
Diaries go back a little bit
cereal companies wouldn't even agree
with you that's why they say part of a
well-balanced breakfast what
bacon and eggs no doubt
that's what I'm saying I take the cereal
some of these are like what De Niro
wrote in his journal in fear no one's
preparing eggs and bacon at their desk
they're hiding Wheaties in the bottom
drawer and
nicking Sandra's milk there we go
dipping your bacon into warm egg yolk is
a religious experience
I think we see where we're going here
I don't know I think it's actually
pretty balanced
dude you're getting ten to one here I
don't think so I'm seeing I don't know
maybe I'm just
since it's pride month I'm gonna go
bacon and eggs because pork hog [__]
eggs come out of the butt squealing
I mean the last 20 have been bacon and
eggs can we give that to the for Pride
let's give that the win
follow oh it's the same guy it's booty
time 69 69 wait a minute didn't we just
give one to booty time success this is
Aaron Berg who is this you think it's a
week booty times we did last night dude
it's so funny for you to go oh it's 40
time 69.
we gave one to booty time no it's just
so funny to just hear you say it and
seriously like booties I know but was
that last episode I don't recall it at
all
well there you go follow booty time 69.
wow all right let's go to the vote
Humble Pie time folks all righty now you
seem to think I'm gonna tell you I'm
gonna guess what the percentages are I
think you're gonna take this one 80 20.
uh I bet you're gonna I think you're
gonna take this one from what I've seen
in the comments I think you're gonna
take this one
83 17. not be surprised if I lose
no no you're gonna have about 83 to 17.
here we go pippy roll that pie chart out
here
okay okay that's almost as close as the
last week's battle was like it's almost
75-25
74.4 goes to eggs and bacon Cold Cereal
gets to 25.6 holy cow what am I at
what's my record this season
you've been teeing off I know and I know
I got to fulfill a second punishment but
I was just gonna say that I'm glad you
said it son of a [__] I'm coming for
you
I thought that was a strong battle
I knew I was gonna lose I knew I was
gonna lose pencil but those last couple
of weeks were were pretty good battles I
like how calm this was too yeah we
needed a calm one the the live stream
got heated yeah or the last episode we
did before the live stream got heated
pencil and Pen got way more yeah than I
thought it would we needed a nice car
this is what was this was a civilized
this was and this is the last time I
will see you before we meet
on our little trip together that's right
this was a nice weekend parting it's a
nice parting sensibility that we have
here I still love you I love you too
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them